hello gamespot it's London Calling
today's Tuesday August nineteenth I'm
Lucy James just a girl standing in front
of the internet on ironically wearing a
nerdy t-shirt underneath a red flannel
shirt I'm not even sorry I'm acting
captain of the good ship GS news today
standing in for Jess MacDonald some
without further ado let's do this news
thing professional procrastinators
rejoice today's appt addition to the
xbox one's roster is none other than the
front page of the Internet it's reddit
optimized for the xbox the red X app
will allow you to access every subreddit
in addition to having your own
customized main page and like scrolling
through the web version you can read
text and view images videos and gifts on
your TV and even zoom in or out for a
closer look the app can be snapped to
the side and with a button press or a
voice command you can upvote or downvote
posts add comments or save any photos
you find to your profile microsoft also
announced that an mtv app is coming to
xbox one featuring sneak peeks bonus
clips and full episodes from select
series if you've got the relevant TV
subscription the twitch app will also be
getting some tweaks including audio
capture from headsets the optional
ability for Kinect to follow and zoom in
on your face and you'll now be able to
see which twitch broadcasts your buds
are watching and then join them in
watching the same broadcast the latest
update for Grand Theft Auto 5 is the san
andreas flight school the free update
which launches today includes some new
jets and helicopters for use in some
aerial solo challenges as well as some
new land vehicles for those of you who
want to pimp your parachutes there'll be
some new designs based on flags from
around the world and it looks like
they'll be new Air Force style attire
available to the update also introduces
a couple of changes to GTA online
including bigger rewards for completing
more difficult missions and bonus
in-game money for doing missions with
others the san andreas flight school is
the latest free update for GTA 5 but the
eagerly-anticipated online heists
haven't been released yet as rock star
of said they're taking more time to
create than anticipated Warner Brothers
have announced a DLC season pass for
their upcoming talking RPG middle-earth
shadow of mordor it'll set you back 25
hobbiton fun bucks
but will include the exclusive guardians
of the flaming I mission which grants
you the rising flame moon upon
completion you'll also get early access
to the trials of war challenge series
and some brand-new story missions
including lord of the hunt which sees
you put on your hunting attire to track
and kill some of more doors more
volatile wildlife there's also the
bright Lord mission where you play as
Keller Brumbaugh the forger of the rings
of power and the Wraith who's attached
to the main protagonist Italian the
Ranger the DLC pass also includes access
to future content such as rooms and
skins middle-earth shadow of Mordor will
launch on sep tember 30th for xbox 360
xbox one ps3 ps4 and PC so that about
does it for today's news blast are you
ready to read it on the Xbox one have
you given up hope for seen those GTA
online heists a DLC season pass what are
you talking about let me know in the
comments GS news is getting ready to hop
on a transatlantic flight ready to come
at you from San Francisco again tomorrow
with Chris waters make sure you tune in
then